what's going on reject nation Greg Alva
here Alisa be crazy
Alisa be crazy from twitch and YouTube
or she live stream also has game Tavern
that's on YouTube we're her and Dan and
a bunch of friends or a couple would get
together and play games it's a lot of
fun links in description box make sure
to follow her Alyssa plays games III was
going on oh my goodness
I'm sure you guys are sick of my
disclaimer about this my gamer friends
are coming on out they're out the week
cuz I'm not a huge gamer but I bring on
people who play the games so that way
the videos somewhat worth watching
yeah I get excited I still see this did
you know me like I don't go out of my
way to play a lot of games on my own but
when I'm with like you or Dan I'm like
yeah let's play some game I Lillian do
it again alright Kingdom Hearts 3 um
hearts yes this is a huge deal because
we believe for Kingdom r3 for freaking
ever communal arts to came out for the
PlayStation 2 so it's been a while
little oil I mean they've been releasing
like little like little games in between
for you know the handhelds and stuff
like that but it's not the 3rd and this
is the sir oh my god the one that one
we've been waiting for see I wouldn't
been able to no idea that's I see it
alright Kingdom Hearts 3 Orchestra
trailer don't assume your dreams are
just fantasy if you can imagine well
believing it that by Walt Disney
[Music]
Wow
[Music]
oh my god - it maleficents insulting a
Haiti
okay
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Wow there is so much you can do in this
like a really cool secret
you noticed a little sense of necessity
to use logic to be yummy
it builds my heart such joy house in our
lifetime
oh my god don't even like okay it is a
legitimate feat to try to explain the
plot of Kingdom Hearts okay I like it
hardly I only know one person who can
just go on and on and on about the plot
and I'm like yes that is a canary so
it's like a combination of made-up
fictional characters for the game and
actual Disney characters yes well it's
okay so Square Enix and did me okay come
on
gotcha one it is legitimately difficult
to sing I've been desire to get it it's
a good time basically if you like Disney
at all and you were going to like this
if you like Square Enix you're going to
like it I'm playing the first one over
and got to Alice so wonderful wonderful
is the resort different museums and you
go between like the different realms in
every realm is like a different Disney
character in their respective place so
it's like they did me cinematic universe
is exactly what I'm drawn to is when you
see like Maleficent and Hades and PD
talking yeah that's nice to me is what I
am drawn to is I wanted to see more of
that stuff that is nothing that you get
to see the characters do interact with
each other and you can like go between
the worlds and there's always like
something going on in the background and
there's the main guy all right Sora this
is key the square-enix characters are
they already established characters or
they made up carriers for Kingdom Hearts
I believe they've been established okay
it sounds like the basic gist of it is
the Sora character house fight the
enemies like within like the Disney
World
gotcha okay so like Maleficent and hey
like this yeah about that remain that
the bad guys are just the bad guys and
and we're fighting against them okay
cool the forces of evil is like the
Disney Cinematic Universe yes this is
the BCE yeah oh yeah this sounds like a
very convoluted complicated plot it's
ridiculous it's absolutely absurd I mean
it looks fun I like like that and I like
what's the word like hack and slash yeah
it's very fun to keep it like to keep it
fun but the story is insane yeah I mean
the gameplay looks and sound like man
you do all this crap in the gameplay I
was like I don't know I could keep up
with all that while I'm playing the game
like remember to do all these movies and
I'm like button mashing on fighting
people the things that I kind of noticed
from the third compared to the first I
mean of course you know over the years
there's going to be development it's
going to get better
the first is very clunky it's very hard
to control in certain ways and just
gonna be want to go that way doesn't
necessarily mean it's gonna cut our way
but from the gameplay it looks like all
of that has gone away how much better
and easier to control well this has left
me a little more formed at a little more
confused hey subscribers real reject
Alyssa be crazy
Alyssa be crazy on YouTube and Twitter
see live streams and plays games and
game tavern where her and Dan Seibert
get together with a couple of friends
and they play games it's an all-around
collective fun of gaming world
check her out NASA yes ma'am in fact I'm
going to be streaming will continue
streaming the first Kingdom Hearts so
I'm currently doing that if you want to
catch up to where we are in a wonderland
we're starting from there we're going to
keep going
ah so I started to three missing men
yeah another fun fact gorillas have
silverback exist
all right back back gorilla